the only thing I had going for me was I
just kept going it took me 350 videos
public videos until I could watch myself
back on camera 350 video and it took 700
something before I thought I was good
one video I made is like that's not bad
let's go I'm starting to get this thing
700 public videos in I just kept going
the only thing I had for me was I kept
going and when people ask me how I
always focus on who I was serving
instead of who I wasn't so if you have
50 people who watch your video a lot of
people see those failure only 50 people
you spend all that time and only 50
people watch that video If You're Gonna
Go speak at a rotary club and 50 people
showed up you'd be excited you'd be
nervous and I would just assume that for
one of those 50 people it's a
life-changing video